this is from the daily wire it says the
capital police officer who shot
protester ashley babbitt was found to be
acting lawfully
and in line with department policy and
will not face internal sanctions the
capital police said on monday the daily
wire reported friday that the officer
who shot babbitt as she entered the
capital speaker's lobby through a broken
window
was formal formally exonerated after the
capitol police conducted an internal
investigation according to an internal
document
the internal capital police
investigation represented the latest
such open investigation into the
circumstances surrounding the 35 year
old trump supporter's death
a memo on the matter obtained by nbc
news said that no further action will be
taken in this manner meaning that the
officer who will not be named will not
face discipline
uh the capital piece unveiled the report
itself on monday officials said
they had interviewed multiple witnesses
and reviewed video and radio calls as
part of the months-long probe
so
radio calls that we haven't heard
uh video we've seen a couple of videos
that were taken by
people in the crowd
cell phone video
i'm going to assume that the capitol
police
looked at security video the security
cameras all over the place in that
building we haven't seen those
we haven't even been told the name of
the person who did this
and they say now as they said all along
that they're not going to tell us the
name they're not going to release the
name because of because of threats
and i could respect that
and i would be fine with that
if not for the fact
that every single time there's a
shooting that blm is upset about we find
out the police officer's name right away
and it doesn't matter if there's threats
i mean you can have some of the most
prominent famous visible people in the
country lebron james
uh making threats
and doxing the officer putting his
putting his uh
his image out there
and still they're gonna give us all the
information
that is demanded about that officer
just like they did in that case in the
makai brian shooting
so if this was a general policy of we're
not going to release the officer's name
unless they're charged with a crime but
if they're not charged with a crime
we're not going to release their name
because of concerns for the safety of
their family and also it's not fair to
them because if it turns out that the
shooting was justified it's not fair
that now that their name is out there
and they got to live in fear for the
rest of their lives
because of this
um i could respect that
if that was the policy but it's not
because again in every other case at
least if blm is upset we find out the
officer's name
this is the only case that i can think
of in recent memory
where there was a police shooting that
was uh controversial
and they didn't tell us the name
and it just so happens it's the one
shooting that blm
is not only unconcerned with and doesn't
care about but they're actually happy
about it they're cheering it on
they're happy that this woman died
because she's white and uh and they
don't agree with her politics
and as we've known along blm
couldn't possibly give less of a damn
about about police shootings that's not
that's never been what this is about
so that doesn't work
um
but we're supposed to i guess move on
now
because the capitol police
without showing us any of the video
without giving us any of the information
that they have
without letting us us hear from the
witnesses that they supposedly talk to
and without even telling us the name of
this person
they have looked into it and they said
we didn't the capitol police have
decided the capitol police didn't do
anything wrong
well that's it then i guess i mean if
the capitol police
if the capital police say they didn't do
anything wrong then i guess they didn't
do anything wrong
and again all of
these all of the people who who normally
hate the police
to say that they distrust the police
would be a massive understatement
i mean they believe that that police
officers are by and large racist serial
killers
and yet in this case they say well if
the police say it was fine then it was
probably fine
it's an absolute joke
um
and at the very least this man's name
should be should be released and i you
know
it's it's the capital police aren't the
only ones who know this guy's name
i can guarantee you every single
republican in congress knows who the guy
is they all know
and they could tell us but they don't
donald trump
was president when this happened
he absolutely knows who did it
in fact he said it he said he has said
that he knows who did it
he's not telling us
so i don't just put the blame on
democrats and uh and the capital police
it's the same story again with
republicans
going along with the flow being
spineless gutless
jellyfish
when they could come out and say no this
is wrong
here you know there should at least be
some transparency with this
here's the man who did this
they could even probably arrange to leak
the security footage if they wanted to
that is what democrats would do
need it even be said you reversed the
situation here
and this was it was a capital police
officer who shot a a an unarmed blm
activist female
you know because she was crawling
through a window
and
she was shot and killed by capital
police
they don't tell us the name they're not
transparent about it
you can guarantee the democrat party
they would have that name out there they
would have the footage out there they
would have all the information in the
public immediately
[Music]
instead we have republicans that just
sit on their hands and say well there's
nothing we could do i guess that's it
let's move
on well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt well show if you did go
ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content